on est les premiers à travailler avec
l'intelligence artificielle dans le
domaine de la santé en tunisie
[Musique]
a été close et des jeunes c'est une
plateforme web qui est basique avec
l'intelligence artificielle et qui
fournit aux médecins dentistes aux
hôpitaux publics que privés en rapport
instantané et complet de l'image
radiologique en fait c'est une combine
deuxième aux plaignants qui va assister
le médecin elle veut elle va nous
proposer un diagnostic il va dire
pourquoi c'est on a proposé ce
diagnostic et le médecin il va soit
s'appuyer sur ce diagnostic soit il peut
les changer
[Musique]
au début on était très sceptique parce
qu'ils ont cru que l'intelligence
artificielle il va les remplacer mais en
fait c'est pas ça mais l'intelligence
artificielle c'est une assistance aux
médecins qu'elle va donner une vue
globale
je pense que l'intelligence artificielle
c'est le futur maintenant il ne va pas
remplacer les médecins mais en fait et
va être une très grande résistance on va
utiliser les deniers pour offrir plus la
recherche les statistiques pour avoir
des résultats qui sont plus précis non
pas des résultats aléatoires et tout ça
il va adopter aussi le recul clinique
pour adapter chaque traitement avec
chaque patient et avoir des résultats
meilleurs
[Musique]